I think the myths are like the parable
of Jesus if you try to resolve it
narratively you mess it up you lose it
right like and I think that I think what
Plato's doing and what the Bible are
doing is saying look you're always going
and this is you know and this is in the
Symposium you're always in between the
taksu you're always always going to be
in between and stop trying to be either
an animal or a God you're always going
to be in between and this is really
relevant right now as we're facing a lot
of emerging technologies that are going
to put a strain on us around that
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm really excited to announce that we
have just put up the new symbolic World
website this new website you know marks
the return of the blog symbolic World
blog the return of the reading list and
also a brand new symbolic World
Community which is accessible and will
be hosted directly on the website this
community can be accessed by anybody who
subscribed to the symbolic world for
those who are who were already
subscribed and supporting us a different
level of patronage either through PayPal
patreon or subscribe star all you need
to do is put in your email address you
will get a reset link for your password
and you are in and for everyone
everybody else it seems like a good time
to join the symbolic world to access all
these new things we're also offering a
few new gifts to everybody who
subscribes even at the level of free
subscriber just to thank everybody for
all the support you have given us all
through all these years and I have to
say it's just beginning we will soon be
announcing new courses uh you know
Richard Roland is preparing a course on
Beowulf there are all these new projects
the new Snow White Project God's dog and
the symbolicworld.com will be the place
to follow this and to get news and you
know some uh a few Peak sneak peeks at
what is coming in the future so thanks
everybody for support and like I said
we're just starting
[Music]
so hello everyone I am excited to be
here one with our usual friend and
collaborator John rabiki who everyone
here knows but then also I'm happy to
introduce you to Jacob Howland uh he is
he is sorry I forget the name of the
program you're you're you're leading but
he is at the University of Austin and is
an expert on Plato and he just told us
that he wrote a book on the talmud and
Plato which both John and I would be
very excited to look at and to read
we've been having several email
exchanges and we both John and I have
been really impressed by his Insight on
on the Greeks the agents and how they're
relevant to us today and also noticing
the University of Austin and just the
courage they have uh kind of to create
something new something fresh uh that is
they're trying to engage with culture
today so Jacob thanks for thanks for
joining us today oh it's really
wonderful to be here Jonathan I've
listened to you and to John uh on many
occasions and I'm absolutely delighted
to participate in this conversation
well it's a great thrill for me to be
able to talk to you Jacob uh like I said
I've uh your book has had a huge impact
on me and I'm very grateful for that
thank you
and so Jacob you kind of you kind of
wrote us several at least several
messages I got several messages from you
with John in the in the messages and you
were you've been poking at some of the
discussions we've been having some of
the relevance of the ancient Greeks to
the modern world today so I'll let you
kind of start us off and then and then
we'll see where it leads us
yeah well thanks
um you know I think uh this particular
conversation was stimulated by uh
discussion you and John were having at
uh in one podcast about played a
symposium and you were talking about the
myth of Aristophanes and I thought you
know there's a lot more there that I
think um both of you could
um really uh relate to and and that we
could sort of tease out more of the
significance of that myth uh in the
Symposium so maybe the way to frame it
is to say that um both the Greeks and
the Bible are very interested in the
relationship between aggression and
sexuality these sort of two fundamental
forces
um so if we start with uh the Greeks you
know we have the uh the legend of he
said where everything emerges out of
chaos you know and you've got this uh
Heavenly god Uranus who covers Gaia
right Heaven is his name and he covers
Earth and and they have Offspring and
then he Stuffs the children back into
the Earth you know and Gaia plots with
uh her children including Chronos who
eventually castrates his father Uranus
and from from his genitalia that fall
into the sea is born Aphrodite which is
very interesting because that's the kind
of connection between you know here's
the symbol of male potency and really
aggression in the case of this God and
from there comes Eros which sort of
introduces in a way the story that
Aristophanes tells if we look over at
the Odyssey For example to take another
ancient Greek epic or story
Odysseus you know spends his time trying
to get back home from Troy and he's
constantly being trapped by these
aggressive women you know Calypso keeps
him as a boy toy for seven years on the
island London Cersei turns his men into
pigs and even school and charybdis are
Representatives these female sort of
monsters remember school is the
six-headed one that plucks men from his
ship and charyptus as the Whirlwind and
I think this is actually
um can be traced to uh the the result of
the um the Greek uh war against Troy
because the cities were emptied of men
and then women kind of moved into the
center of power and obviously in the
case of the Bible you've got these very
strange stories
um in the Bible it's not the case that
as with Odysseus you're trying to get
back to civilization but you're trying
to the Bible is exploring how do we
create civilization how do men and women
um figure out what it means to be a
couple what it means to be a mother or a
father how to relate these drives of
sexuality and uh and aggression and I
think that's something that's really
Central to aristophany Smith
so how do you see it connected air to
Aristophanes I'm curious well so you
know in this in this myth in the
Symposium and maybe I should also give a
little bit of framing here
um the Symposium of course is a dialogue
by Plato and the subject is love
um the occasion is
um a party celebrating the poet
agathon's victory at um one of the
Athenian dramatic festivals
and everyone gathers at agathon's house
and
um there are seven speeches recorded in
the Symposium and it turns out that um
through through an accident aristophany
speech is the central speech and this is
important because in Plato I would say
in Sophocles and we also see this in in
other poets and writers of our own day
the center of a text is particularly
important Aristophanes was supposed to
speak third in the order of seven but he
got the hiccups uh and so he switched
places with a doctor named Eric simicus
and he ends up speaking forth I think
this is important because the way I see
the dialogue is that Aristophanes lays
out a kind of anthropology okay uh and
Central to the anthropology is both the
relationship between sort of Untamed
sexuality and Untamed aggression and
then custom in particular the rights and
uh laws and um
rituals that are related to The Olympian
gods and the last speech in the dialogue
is that of el sobieties this flamboyant
aggressive erotic Greek uh famous
warrior
um kind of an uncontrolled man uh his uh
he had a shield and on the shield was
Eros right the god of love with a
thunderbolt right which combines both
aggression and sexuality
and in between those two speeches is the
speech of Socrates who has a who has
this lovely account of how the soul
longs to come into the presence of the
beautiful and into the presence of
transcendent goodness and beauty and
there's a sense in which I think the
dialogue is a contest between the
account of Aristophanes which
prioritizes aggression we are
fundamentally aggressive beings the
account of Socrates which is very
attractive by the way to Christians and
to later religious thinkers because the
object of Eros is these this
Transcendent truth and Beauty
um the contest between them is in a way
uh determined or were asked to think
about how sobieties a kind of confused
erotic and aggressive man in connection
with those two speeches
so that's a that's a kind of framing
um but I'm happy to then uh continue uh
with kind of a discussion of of what
Aristophanes is saying in in his myth
but maybe we can stop and see if there's
any any thoughts about about this
I mean I think it I've always found the
Symposium interesting when you
understand also that there's a kind of
the context
um of our society is being the betrayer
you know this idea that later on in the
story this is what's going to happen
he'll he'll be one of the causes of the
fall of Athens uh and so in some ways
you already have this Frame where his
this passionate aggressive person uh you
you kind of know where it where it goes
you know where it leads and so I think
that's also one of the reasons probably
why Christians found the basic notion of
the Symposium interesting you know
because because there's a sense when
these these passions out of control and
then are are leading to the destruction
of the city and Socrates is trying to
you know in that story of the seduction
between between him and al-sibilities
you get a sense of Socrates is
constantly trying to kind of be there
and then take his desire and move it up
towards something more towards towards
the beautiful you know yeah that's
exactly right and look the Symposium is
set drama medically because we actually
know I mean agathon was a historically
existing individual and we know that he
won this prize in in the year 416 right
in the eve of the Sicilian Expedition
that was an expedition a crazy far-flung
expedition to Sicily the Athenians had
this idea
to send their whole Navy over to Sicily
it ended in disaster but the prime mover
was also biodies and his plan was to
take the Athenians over to Sicily to
conquer the rich city of Syracuse to
conquer the rest of Sicily to then use
the money and the sort of impressed
slaves that they've conquered to uh to
conquer Carthage and then to take the
whole force and go over and conquer the
Persians right sort of they have cop
World Conquest it ended absolutely
disastrously but one of the interesting
things and some people have speculated
that Plato is suggesting that on the
night of the Symposium when at the end
of the dialogue alphabides comes in
completely drunk with a bunch of uh his
sort of kotari of friends that that
might have been the night that
alcibiotes participated in or was
alleged to participate in the
desecration of the Herms now there were
these statues of Hermes and uh Hermes is
depicted with genitalia and somebody
went around and by the way the sections
of Hermes he's sort of a god of the
crossroads and stuff so there would be
intersections in Athens and statues of
Hermes Somebody went around and
mutilated the Herms by cutting off
his sex organs and that's a very um
let's say anti-erotic gesture
so you know in the background of this is
this theme of Ira said let me say one
more thing
um
I would suggest that one of the Great
accomplishments of Plato is to
reinterpret Eros if you read thucydides
history of the pillow of the uh of the
Peloponnesian War
um the word Eros occurs about six times
and Eros isn't just sexual passion in
ancient Greek but it's it's any kind of
really powerful passion and when it
occurs in thucydides it's essentially a
dirty word it's like for example in the
Sicilian Expedition he says that Heroes
for the Expedition fell upon the
Athenians and the Greek word fall is the
same same word you'd use if a disease
sort of fell upon
um and so what Plato does is he says
it's not Euros the problem isn't Euros
it's the objects of Euros what human
beings have a passion for is money and
power and pleasure and so forth we've
got to redirect it toward these
Transcendent things
so this is very rich background I think
um for for these discussions and in the
Christian Aesthetics end up recapturing
arrows although in the Bible itself it's
not the the word that's used the most
for sure the Aesthetics end up bringing
the word back and so you hear you read
the Aesthetics talk about arrows as the
prime uh let's say the prime drive
towards Union with God and that it is
actually Eros that leads us into into
theosis so so you can see that they
really bring back some of some of these
ideas that are there in Plato
yeah you know it's interesting though
because what we're going to see in
Aristophanes is that um Eros is a kind
of cure or uh kind of medicine let's say
to
um to arrest our aggression or at least
uh uh ensure that it doesn't have sort
of the worst consequences
um in the Bible it's very interesting
because if you look at the story of Adam
and Eve
um it isn't until the introduction of
Euros that is the splitting of the whole
human being whom God created called
hadam the human being God created male
and female and remember that
Adam Adam can't find a partner and then
God finally puts them to sleep and and
and and and and and and cuts part of him
right and sort of makes uh Eve out of
out of part of this whole human being
it's then interestingly that sort of
trouble starts right
um for example I've always been struck
that uh you know there's this line in uh
in Genesis where it says that uh
Adam awoke
and the the verse says right this is
their primordially whole human being
spoke and he said that's bone of my bone
and Flesh of My Flesh she's gonna be
called Isha woman because she came from
ish man but this is the this is uh this
is a mistake because woman didn't come
from ish the male woman came from Haddam
the whole human being and so Adam and
his excitement gets this the male
becomes so excited that he breaks into
this poetry and and he says she came
from me but actually
the woman is taken apart from this
primordially whole human being and ish
the male part is all that's left over so
under the influence of Eros
the male becomes confused and believes
that he is the source of woman right
there's a kind of forgetting of God it's
very strange in that story does this
make sense so that so that there's no it
makes sense because there's some weird
things that happen in the Christian
commentaries you know you when you you
read uh in Saint Gregor Nissa and other
of the the early commentators they'll
say things like the separation of Adam
is a preview of The Fall it's done it's
done knowing that they say things like
God knew the fog was going to happen and
it is done in preview of the fall and
there's a deep Insight even structurally
in terms of Storytelling because the
fact that Adam is put to sleep
in order to for this to happen is the
preview of death it gets a little death
that seems to happen that causes the
division between the two and then you
see as you move towards the freed of the
the the fruit of the knowledge of Good
and Evil you're moving towards a world
of opposites basically uh so I they
never go so far as to say that it's
wrong they'll say that it's good but
that they have a sense in which it's
like you said there's already some
movement uh towards a kind of broken
multiplicity even in the the separation
yeah that's you know that's so
interesting and then of course sexuality
figures and this is um if we sort of go
back to the Jewish tradition
um uh so Rashi the medieval commentator
um when when he's commenting on on the
serpents
um seduction of Eve right and he says oh
did God really tell you you can't eat
this tree no he knows you know you you
know you're become as gods or as my
Marley says as as kings the word Elohim
can be translated that way Rashi says
the serpent one to sleep with Eve and
that the serpent actually believed that
the fruit would kill right that if you
eat of the fruit you'll die and so and
this is a really strange explanation
okay but uh and that that he believed
the Eve was intelligent and he was going
to take the fruit and because she was
intelligent she was going to test it on
Adam first and give it to him and he'd
eat it he'd die and then the serpent
would have beef now what's it's a crazy
story but what's interesting there is
the suggestion that sexual Eros confuses
right and seduces and kind of messes us
up right which you know which which I
think is a human experience
um but what's fascinating is that that
particular story kind of reverses the
order of Aristophanes because
Eve gets this idea right it's after the
division and you've got woman and man
Eve gets the idea that hey I'm gonna eat
this fruit I'm gonna violate God's
commandment right because either I will
become like a god or if my mother is
right like a king but I'm going to reach
for something
um and it's an act of aggression right
um
that is a reversal of Aristophanes
because in Aristophanes what's
primordial is aggression and Eros
follows uh uh from
um a kind of a divine intervention to
try to sort of Tamp down aggression
um
now that I think of it though I guess
that that you could you could sort of
see I mean Eros doesn't exist in either
case until some action of God some
action of of of splitting right so this
is a kind of way that the the Bible in
Aristotle sort of match up with each
other
um
so um
did you guys have been saying so much I
don't know where to uh make a comment
but um maybe first to return to the
symposium
so one way I've often framed uh
socrates's Speech is the speech between
Aristophanes and emojis I just dropped
the name
and so I mean for me uh I I quite also
look the overlaps right so uh the
contrast and the continuities are really
important uh I think and this is what
Plato was playing with dramatically of
course there's a continuity between in
the aristophanese myth the seeking for
wholeness that gets taken up in uh
diatima's uh Ascent the anagogue at
assent and of course the neoplatonist
made a great deal of that overlap
um but it's important to realize that
that that sort of ascent uh the the Sikh
did the right I think I agree with you
Jacob the the idea of the ascent I mean
platinus takes this up you know the
knowing is the the way we get whole and
we have to know the right things in
order to ascend and I think that theme
is taken up but the Elsa body speech
reminds us about something important
um buchnik I think makes a good case for
this and the tragedy reason is that
there's nothing necessary to the ascent
the ascent is contingent there's no
there's right it doesn't it's not it's
not you know once you start you won't
necessarily go up all the levels it's
contingent all the way along and the and
the presence of our sovieties is to
remind us of that it's like here's a
person who literally hangs out with
Socrates it's deeply attracted to
Socrates wants to be one with Socrates
probably even in a sexual Manner and yet
he doesn't go through the anagogical
ascent and so I think what we're being
said what's what we're being told here
is there's a there's a potential
transformation
available in in that that seeking for
for for
wholeness which I think is the
primordial thing behind both the
aggression and the Eros right
um
that it has a possible transformation
but there's something very tragic about
it because there's no necessity to it uh
we can enter into it but we are quite
liable to fail in a profound way and
that says to me something very
um significant about
uh the relationship that Plato's trying
to draw between Eros and anagogue and uh
logos uh because of course a theme that
unites all of these is this theme of
giving birth right and and so as you go
up the ascent you're giving birth to low
guard you're giving birth and it's not
just speeches it's also ways of seeing
ways of understanding and this and he
also says you know
um the Quest for immortality sexual
immortality is something that we can
sort of transform into uh Oneness with
eternity if I can use those contrasts
and so I see all three speeches as
trying to tell us there is something
available to you but there is
there's great tragedy available also
possible in that
um you can transform this primordial
quest for wholeness into the ascent to
the one or the good
um but there's no necessity in that and
Plato's really wrestling with something
here I think was just really profound
which is we see we have this weird
relationship with his prime more Joel it
seems to overpower us but we seem to
have options to transform it but those
options aren't guaranteed either it like
for me that the finitude and the
Transcendence are so bound together in
this in in sort of an almost
you know I keep coming back to the word
tragedy right like it's we're bound to
it we have this capacity for Ascent but
we all and we can transform that
primordial desire
but we can also just be overwhelmed by
it and then I think the question that
emerges for me is what makes the
difference it's not even the presence of
Socrates that makes the difference like
I come away from those three speeches
sort of wandering deep into Play-Doh
like what makes the difference because
as I I've tried to late what I think his
argument is there's no necessity right
so what and I you know and Plato's not I
think offering just sort of a base well
you just choose I don't think it's a raw
existentialism or something I think
there's a there's like a
sorry but I I I I'm really on the edge
of what I'm trying to speak to here but
there's something there that what makes
the difference between an El sobieties
and a Socrates that goes up the ascent
and for me that's that's the thing that
sort of resonates
um because we're in the face of this
god-like thing right Eros and and it's
in between the Divine and the human
and we're in that between place what
makes the difference like we're because
we're in the in between there's no
necessity either way but what makes the
difference that's what comes out for me
as the question and so the Greeks for me
uh well Plato sorry uh Plato in the way
he puts the speeches together raises
this profound kind of question
um that
um perhaps we could address to the Bible
um and say what makes that difference
and you know and I think there's
something going on
um I'm a little more hesitant to talk
about the Bible uh but there's something
going on about what I mean Jonathan as I
understand what you said and I've read a
little bit of the fathers it's like
they're trying to get with like this
this was going to happen but
nevertheless
you chose it to happen and there's a
necessity but if there's a choice and
it's good and it's bad like there's a I
find that the two are resonating at this
point of what is making the difference
so that's what that's what I want to
bring to this if I like Mike very very
Christian reading of the Symposium so
I'm not gonna you're gonna apologize for
that but
the so when I what I see like when I
when I remember the the symposium
is that what makes a difference it seems
it seems that there's something Socrates
is trying to do something without
sobieties yes like he recognizes the the
arrows and he he knows in some ways that
this Eros like he like Jake like you
said this is the means by which
you can reach up and so and he seems to
be trying to transform his arrows and he
does it in different ways he does it by
kind of bringing him close to him and
then refusing him in some ways or
refusing his advances and then trying to
kind of turn his advances so there seems
to be I think that
this is going to sound like I said very
Christian but it seems like there's a
there's something of asceticism in what
in what Socrates is trying to do it's
like if you experience loss like if you
experience loss of what you desire
and you're able to kind of do that with
the right with the right uh attitude or
the the right mindset then it it's a
it's like a trampoline or it's like a
it's a new ground on which you can reach
higher you know and so if you if you to
some this degree tame or refuse some of
your immediate passions right and you
kind of hold them then you put yourself
in a position where you can maybe
Glimpse through them to something to
something more uh but that's me like
during Lent now moving into Holy Week
saying that well but but
like I I don't I'm not trying to put
that aside I want to put something
beside it which of course you know Plato
uh Compares philosophy to seduction
um to being seduced uh because uh
Plato's trying to deal with sort of you
know questions about how can we know and
not know and the answer seems to be well
love is a kind of knowing and not
knowing it's not a complete ignorance
because it guides Us in some way uh but
it but it's not knowing or or we would
we wouldn't be seeking and questing so
it's the in betweenness it's this
indeterminiveness right that that get
that that's a key in that way you to
draw somebody into that transformation
you have to seduce them you have to you
have to get them to recognize the
knowing and the not knowing and how
they're interpenetrating each other and
so I don't I think it's more Socrates is
at times
I don't think I'm disagreeing with you I
think he does what you said I think he
draws him in and refuses them but I
think that's part of a general thing of
trying to get him into uh you know a
kind of aporia a kind of longing uh you
know so that he'll be seduced towards
the good
um but see that and this gets into again
like this thing you you know again it's
I keep I I think I often find Plato is
driving towards he's trying to get at oh
here's virtue right but you can't teach
it but you have to teach it right what
turns people towards virtue because this
thing keeps coming back again and again
and I think of it as this like profound
questioning and questing at the heart uh
and I I mean sorry I'll shut up I want
to know I've been talking to you I mean
look I think this is this is all
right on track
um the interesting thing about lcbiities
I regard him as a philosophical casualty
right
here's here's this guy and let's just
like alcibiotes is first of all
extremely handsome well-born right he's
a ward of Pericles
um Rich
um gifted as a warrior and a commander
very intelligent
um you know if you read for example
plutarch's life of el sabieties the guy
is like crazy I mean he's you know he
tells stories about how else about is
playing in the road
with his other little boyfriends you
know as a child and a coach comes going
along and all the kids scatter but also
buddy stays there and the guy's like
stops The Chariot he's like you all I
almost killed you and why didn't you get
out of the road and he's like because
I'm playing here you know and then
there's stories about how he would go
into people's houses and just steal
their silver or you know slaps his
father-in-law all kinds of crazy
behavior
um there's a dollar called the first
Elsa bodies there are two dogs called
Elsa bodies and the in the so-called
first El sabiety Socrates place this
seduction game with him right he's it's
kind of he's almost like a pervert in
some weird ways like he watches Elsa
bias as a boy for a long time and then
he approaches him when the kid's like 16
or 17.
um and here's how somebody's again who I
think you know he must have thought I
have everything I am full I am replete
you know because why everybody wants to
be me I am the greatest and what
Socrates does is he says
at one point he says in the dialogue
you're Eros for renowned is greater than
any other person's Eros for anything
ever right like he but it's so
interesting because by the way that's an
ambiguous use of the word Euros because
we're not talking like a love of the
beautiful we're talking about a kind of
combination of aggression and and and
and erotic I mean this weird mysterious
mixture that we find in the human soul
right he wants to be number one and
Socrates says you're not going to be
satisfied with just being the top guy in
Athens you want to rule the world you
want to be greater than Xerxes you want
to be greater than you know the Persian
Emperor um
and and by the way if you want that you
got to come to me I can I can help you
right now of course what else the bodies
finds and what we see as he reveals
himself in his drunkenness and the
Symposium is
I couldn't do it right Socrates is the
only human being who ever made me feel
ashamed now this is after as you said
John Socrates sort of puts him in this
position like you think you have
everything but you don't you're longing
for something more initially it's posed
as like being the ruler of the world or
something right you're longing for
something more you need me but then
Socrates makes him ashamed because of
Socrates virtue right you open them up
and the gods inside and and by the way
Socrates is a Seducer you're absolutely
right
what's so fascinating is here's this
ugly man sort of weird looking guy
um there's a wonderful article called
Socrates as hoplite where the author
it's a something called ancient
philosophy in this journal the author um
does all the research on Socrates and he
shows that Socrates although he was a
poor man somehow got the money together
to buy the the equipment that would
allow him to fight at the level of a Hop
light okay which is a heavily armed
Warrior and then distinguished himself
in battle in fact how somebody talks
about it in the Symposium Socrates saved
my life you know and then he he he he
rejected the honor that the that the
city wanted to give him
um
and so Elsa body sees someone who really
has it all somehow this is I'm going to
just sort of foreshadow here something I
want to come back to later in the
Socrates is replete like the circle
people in Aristotle's myth right like
these like they don't need anything else
he somehow has it
um
but it's the rock that Elsa body splits
on because when I'm with Socrates I have
to do what he says
and when I'm away from him I'm seduced
by the call of the people you know so he
really is this kind of philosophical
casually but I think your question is
very well taken
what is it how how come I mean is it
just the seduction of
of being the great El sobieties and
being looked at
by everyone and and and and regard it as
the object of their Eros that that
prevents him from seeking Beauty and
Truth
hard to say
um but maybe I can talk a little bit
about the air esophagy's myth right
because it occurs to me maybe some
listeners don't really know what the
method so the myth basically is that
human beings originally were these
Circle people
was spherical we had forearms four legs
two faces four ears Four Eyes faces
facing opposite and we rolled all around
right and and and we and and we could do
cartwheels really quickly and we rolled
up to try to attack the gods we got Big
Ideas
and so Zeus is perplexed and he decides
we got to stop these guys
so he cuts us all in half
and the original human beings were
combinations of male male male female or
female female so this is where we get
the Sexes right
and the result is that our haves seek
each other out
and we we long for our other half now
this is a big difference
from Socrates account of Eros because in
also in Aristophanes and kind of bureaus
we seek the other half to make ourselves
whole but we're seeking our original
selves
for Socrates we're seeking something
other we're seeking the ideas we're
seeking the truth we're seeking the
Beautiful
uh but in any case Eros then it like
originally we were aggressive beings we
had big Ideas what we wanted to do is
attack the gods Eros is a kind of
um
um what would you call like divide and
conquer right but but it's a um a kind
of uh distraction because now instead of
attacking the gods vertically we'll go
around horizontally looking for our
other halves we're trying to come
together now look at the tragic
character of this what we really want in
the myth is to be bound back with our
other halves and have our original
Integrity restored should that happen we
would then attack the gods again right I
mean because that's our original nature
so for Aristophanes it's and by the way
this is very true to Aristotle's
existing 11 or surviving 11 comedies
they're all about sex and aggression and
playing them off against each other to
temper aggression so famously lysistrata
now this was a is the the play in which
the Athenian and Spartan women go on a
sex strike to stop the Peloponnesian War
and it works right
um I saw this by the way as a boy in the
1960s my mother took me to a play at the
University of Chicago and it was quite
shocking to me because the the
characters were walking around they had
broomsticks between their legs right the
men were erotically excited remember one
a woman says well if you won't come by
the hand taken by the handle and she
grabs him by the broomstick and drags
them off the stage the air stuffies was
very popular in the 1960s because it was
Make Love Not War right and that really
was Aristotle's message uh and and so
it's the idea of playing these off
against each other
but there's something tragic about her
Stephanie Smith
because cutting people in half it makes
us less strong but it doesn't get rid of
our aggressive nature and it distracts
us and we seek the other and by the way
Eros is prior to sex because uh when the
circle people were cut in half and they
were hugging each other and so forth
um they were dying in each other's arms
and then Zeus says well we got to have a
further operation we'll move their
genitals around to the other side so at
least they can reproduce
um so you know that's a rather tragic
Vision I think the socratic vision is
not tragic except Elsa body story is
tragic
what what if there's so many things
flashing in my mind you know um because
when you were saying you know if they
come together then they attack the gods
right the the phrase that came into my
mind right away was
you know was uh was love God with all
your your all your might and love your
neighbor as yourselves is that it seems
that in
that in in our tradition right that that
in the in the Christian tradition I
think also probably in the Jewish
tradition there's a sense in which if we
that there's an image between coming
together as a people coming together in
love and then then becoming the body the
the you know the place where God upon
which God descends and so in some ways
it's not it doesn't have that
doesn't have that tragic
aggressive idea where if we bind
together then we attack vertically so
right so the top has to keep us separate
in order for there's this really dark
image of how the world Works uh which is
that that which is transcendent you know
divides in order to to rule over it
whereas there is a sense uh in this
image of of agape love right that if we
if we come together then we become the
receptacle the the people with which God
communes
um anyways that's just the image that
came to me right away but there is the
biblical image of nimrod right
and and coming in and God creating all
of the languages because the people were
trying to ascend to God in the tower and
and that so I mean that theme is also
found in the Bible yeah definitely right
right and so and again
um
but it has I think it has to do with I
think I mean this is now bringing it
more into our usual conversation John
but I think that what you see what you
see in in the Tower of Babel and Nimrod
is the idea that they had one language
and they have tried to have one name and
so there's the difference between the
normal distribution of identity that
happens in a in a normal hierarchy and a
kind of uniformity which is that you're
at the top just tries to impose itself
right you see that in the in the myth of
uh of Uranus and Gaia which is that
uranos wants to impose himself on God
but he doesn't want the children he
doesn't want this distribution of his
identity into the world and that's the
that's the problem whereas the normal
let's say the normal kind of organic
hierarchy is where we are the reality of
our love for each other is real and and
the multiplicity that all the variation
all the multiplicity is real and then it
finds like but but the way that it's
together in its variability is because
it's connected to something which
transcends it and so there's this
balance between unity and multiplicity
that happens at all the levels
maybe that reflects I'm thinking of
Telex argument here right
um we
right we seem to be bound by two
opponent drives and I'm trying to see if
this will link up to the relationship
between Eros and aggression we want we
seem to be bound to participate to
integrate to unify and then we seem to
be bound to the drive to individuate to
separate uh to make ourselves different
uh from others and and Telex argument is
that if we try to if we try to stabilize
that by resolving it into one pole or
the other we will actually destroy our
Humanity that our Humanity lies in uh
the polarity and
um I'm I'm so again I'm wondering if we
seem to be caught up in these themes of
we seem to have these like we're drawn
into wholeness but then we can get
hubristic and so we we break apart but
then we get lonely and Adam knew he was
alone right we get lonely and we see to
be oscillating between them and and and
are the myths and I don't mean that word
pejoratively right are the myths
I don't see the myths offering
resolution to that I I'm not here to be
I'm not here just to be a contrarian
right but I I don't see the myths as
offering a resolution I see the myths
are sort of saying that's it like this
is the perennial thing you've got to
accept it you you can't resolve it you
may be drawn in but you're gonna be
you're also going to push apart the Eros
and the and and the aggression are
inseparably bound together because if
you lose one the other will destroy your
Humanity that's that's what I'm hearing
the myths saying and and I thought till
it did a good job of taking that up and
saying look the thing you got to do is
you got to accept right that polarity
you can't resolve it it's it's one of
those tone offs right it's a tonos that
that polarity actually defines your
humanity and so
am I just being quite Frank but I like
I'm trying to I think the myths keeps
saying stop trying to resolve this I
think the myths are like the parable of
Jesus if you try to resolve it
narratively you mess it up you lose it
right like and I think that I think what
Plato's doing and what the Bible are
doing is saying look you're always going
and this is you know and this is in the
Symposium you're always in between
mataksu you're always always going to be
in between and stop trying to be either
an animal or a God you're always going
to be in between and this is really
relevant right now as we're facing a lot
of emerging technologies that are going
to put a strain on us around that
yeah no I think this is really
interesting you know um a couple of
things here
um so
maybe it's useful to kind of go back and
and sort of look at this anthropology
that that Aristotle says laid out these
Circle people are like bouncing around
chaotically right there they can roll
around they can move quickly they're
they're like atoms and by the way the
word atomos means uncuttable right so
they're they're they're bouncing around
and they threaten the gods and so
God has to or Zeus has to has to impose
some order there's got to be some kind
of blow right so this is like the
destruction of the Tower of Babel or the
I don't know the uh explosion from Eden
you know
um and
um what's interesting is that
Aristophanes vocabulary changes
in his description so when he first says
that
um there were these three types male
male male female and female female
um after they're cut in half
he talks about men and women okay not
male and female and men and women are
politicized
males and females okay and the way I
read the myth is that
um Aristophanes is essentially saying
you've got chaos like he see it right
you've got cast now you have to have
order where does order come from
it comes from law namas it comes from
Custom it comes from the Olympians right
that is to say what happens when they're
cut in half aristophany says then they
had to walk upright or sauce right so
you have like orthodoxa Orthodoxy right
they now look what happens here uh I
actually want to suggest at this point
that
uh well I want to go back to what I
hinted at earlier which is Socrates is
kind of like a circle person okay it's
got four ears he's got four in other
words he's sort of in touch with reality
he can hear he can see he can look up
and down and so forth when you're cut in
half
you're now standing up you're looking
forward you're uh you don't have eyes in
the back of your head you're to look at
what at other men and other women
because you're looking for your other
half right you're not to look up toward
the gods and attack them you're not to
look back where you came from you're not
to ask about these fundamental questions
you're not to philosophize right there's
a sense in which the Olympian religion
is antithetical to this kind of
fundamental questing and thinking
I think Aristophanes thinks of
philosophy like Nietzsche does it's it's
a Will To Power okay for Socrates it's
Eros but so what happens here is that
the gods cut and then Aristotle even
says later and by the way if we keep up
our aggression they'll cut us in half
again
incidentally aresophanes who even in the
Symposium it's mentioned like he gets
the hiccups uh and someone says like I
think he overeat you know aristophius
was allegedly a big guy and he liked
food and and he talks about how cutting
apples or eggs you know that's how they
cut the human beings
I think there's more to it than just a
joke here I think the Olympians in the
Greek context we are the food of the
gods they dine on us in Homer in The
Iliad the gods go up with when they're
having the big battles with Achilles at
the end they're sitting in the trees and
they're feasting they're feasting on
human beings and there's a sense in
which they they us they they
they they they you know cutting us in
half they diminish our strength they're
they're and and so who's this human
being Socrates he's somebody who does
attack the gods the Olympians in this in
the Youth of pro for example right he
says I don't like these stories about
Zeus and and Kronos and castrations and
all these kinds of things these are not
the kinds of deities we should be
worshiping they're not worthy of the
name God
now you get in the Hebrew Bible and in
the Christian Bible God feeds us we're
not food of the Gods God speeds us right
so there's some other thing going on
there but but so there's a kind of you
know I don't I actually you know I think
Aristophanes being a poet and having
written the clouds in which Socrates
says we don't credit Gods you know and
suggest that they're made up by each
community
um he doesn't believe in the Olympians
but I think he does believe in some kind
of necessary divine order so to speak or
or necessary Customs that restrict our
sexuality and aggression
um and so all this stuff is sorted out
in a very different way in the Bible but
it still has to be sorted out because
we're still the same human beings
hmm
so you think that
um I want to pick this theme up the one
thing
um that uh
um Socrates is somehow whole I mean this
the Symposium also takes great pains to
identify him with Eros and being
perpetually mataksu not coming to
completion and of course he knows what
he does not know and he can he will
never have wisdom the thing he Longs for
he in fact regularly says he will never
have you can only love it yeah he will
always be mataksu in relationship to it
so I mean isn't Socrates also
um he's also not complete he's also
fundamentally incomplete in that he is
also always always a lover of wisdom
um and also attacks you towards it he
always is because if he came to
completion Eros would end if attacks who
would be over the in between this would
be over and the philosophical question
see I see Socrates right as as always we
talk like there's another there's
another there's another way in which
this plays out in Plato right is there's
another wholeness Socrates is right
there he's always aspiring he's also
he's always aspiring right uh to his
um
well his great herself or you know his
Divine double to use Charles stings
where he talks about he goes home and
there's somebody waiting for him at home
which is Socrates but that Socrates is
gonna you know question him about the
day and what did you do when he's got
his demonian right that speaks to him
right I see him see I I see him as as
still divided and still seeking a kind
of fullness but what Plato's trying to
do is to say you know that wholeness
that you're and that you're seeking in
other people you're also divided against
yourself in a fundamental way that's
what foolishness is and you know Plato
makes a big deal of that in the Republic
we're divided against ourselves and what
we're actually seeking is a way to come
into relationship to our aspirational
divine double to come into uh what you
know a kind of well something like
wisdom like the kind of uh completeness
and so
yes I see I'm not denying what you're
saying Socrates is clearly exemplary but
I see Plato is holding those two
together he's yeah he's somehow more
like the circle people but he's also
still divided he's all he's clearly
divided and he's still always in in
between and still he's on a quest that
he will never complete by his own and
repeated admission uh and so yes
uh first of all does that land as a as a
as some as a proposal to you absolutely
look Socrates is fundamentally
paradoxical right yes I mean look you
know like let's just take the apology
right he's like you know he says
basically two things you know that you
know I am
he doesn't quite put it this way but you
know the God sent me right to you I am
sort of a gift of the god to the city
right and I am a gadfly which you know
I'll bite you and you'll kill me right
well is he a species of pestilence a
gadfly or is he God's gift you know I
mean you could sort of look but what's
interesting here is so let's try to
define the wholeness in some way
if I post the question you read the
speech of Elsa bodies does he love
Socrates or does he hate Socrates right
yeah and the answer is yes right I mean
sometimes I wish he's dead sorry so and
this goes back to the aggression and the
sexuality right like like it kills him
that Socrates is greater than he is and
he makes it very clear that he is yeah
you know this man is so great now he
interprets Socrates as he says it's just
ironic you know he's just playing a game
with us and so forth and that's I don't
think that's quite true but but let's
look at Socrates speech Socrates
basically says aggression is
misunderstood Eros through Moss is
misunderstood Euros what we really want
is to come into the presence of the
beautiful and bring forth in Beauty
and people misunderstand that right and
they you know they get the reproduction
and the immortality and stuff but they
seek honor or children or whatever it
may be
so he doesn't have that split in his
soul
like there's a kind of inner integrity
and what's really interesting about
soccer I agree with you completely John
and by the way I agree with Kierkegaard
here my Socrates is kind of Kierkegaard
Socrates suck you know there's a point
in uh concluding unscientific postgroup
where kindergarten says um you know
Socrates is never finished he's always
striving and most people like when it
comes to education they want to say I'm
educated they want to be done with
things but Socrates is sort of like this
almost like an open wound you know like
it's he's constantly questing and yet
he has Equanimity you know I'll just
give you an example at one point and
this this occurred to me and I was sort
of delighted with my own Insight on this
um at one point you know Aristotle Elsa
body is talking about how Socrates
behaved in battle right and he says you
know the guy was a great warrior and so
he says and um nobody could enjoy a
feast like Socrates could
but then again when food was scarce
nobody could stand up to hunger you know
the way he could now what's interesting
is
like the way he puts it is like Socrates
alone could like really enjoy a food why
couldn't the other guys enjoy a meal
because they're scared
like Socrates is not afraid he is
um he is he has a kind of equanimity his
soul is not anxious and troubled I would
say the way that there's like alcibiotes
is so there's a kind of wholeness that
comes through being filled by Beauty and
being filled by now again he's questing
for these things but to some extent
he does achieve the nourishment of the
beautiful you know it's not that he's
like in the fedris in other places he
talks about how the true nourishment of
the soul is truth is the ideas
and I and I think that that's a
statement from his own experience right
like he does get something out of
philosophy it's not as if he's simply
striving and never achieving I agree I
agree totally and this is what after
Socrates is wrestling with all the way
through I mean you've got these weird
this weird like wisdom is you have you
you and virtue would result from you
learning and knowing in some way and yet
he he fundamentally knows that he
doesn't know but somehow he still
becomes the wisest and and most just man
you know that's what's at the Fatal
which is pronounced over his death you
know he was the greatest and and for me
that that that's that that's the that's
the tricky thing because
it reminds me of so we have Christianity
and Judaism so I'll bring in some
Buddhism too it reminds me of the Zen
um and and it goes back to this this
thing that I'm trying to get at what
makes the difference you know yeah you
know you don't get Enlightenment by
seeking it but only those who seek it
will become enlightened right and these
kinds of these kinds of paradoxical
things about it if you say you're wise
that's definitely evidence that you're
not wise but then how could you ever
know that you were wise how could you
even know you were making progress
there's all these and this is what I get
I keep seeing this tremendous tension
that you're constantly if you try and
settle it down then you're you're losing
something and for me this goes down to I
think Plato's now this is going to be a
vervakian argument
um so I'll just put the cards on the
table I think Plato's seeing something
deep about intelligibility itself
that intelligibility is this constant
evolving tension between integration and
differentiation if things only did
differentiated we wouldn't understand
them if they became a homogeneous one we
could not understand them they're and
and and they're you know and the
postmodernists like derida have made
great uh careers out of this but and you
can't also you can't stabilize it you
can't say okay now we've got the perfect
balance because that will also kill
intelligibility so for me I think Plato
is trying to get us to see profoundly
that right at the core of logos is this
fundamental paradoxical tension and I
see that eventually taken up I think I
see Socrates is learned ignorance right
that he does taken up in Nicholas acuza
you know you do this you really push
intelligibility and get all these
Paradox and then you come to realize
that you can't act the ground of
intelligibility can't be captured within
intelligence ability itself and I see
that as what is fundamentally going on
here it's like look right you stop it
right you can't make this stop and and
so
what we most if we are the creatures
that of logos we can't ultimately fully
possess ourselves because we can't bring
logos to completion to finish and I so
again and and I think Socrates I think
your point is Right Socrates is the best
and yet he still isn't you know he
doesn't say I'm done I'm finished it's
okay right but can I I just want to say
something because I both of the both of
these are just kind of bouncing around
my head in terms of if you think of of
the speech Aristophanes and you have
this idea of the the union of at a
horizontal level right and and the idea
that in some ways Socrates is not
you know when Jacob you say that he is
that round person right he is that round
guy and so because he's that round guy
then his eyes can look up towards the
God so in some ways like you said he is
trying to take he is trying to reach
into this fear of the Gods he is trying
to move up vertically towards that which
should be the place of the Gods
um and so and and what's interesting
about that is
that's why he can also live in this
world of horizontality in the in a way
that is celebratory right so it's like
because he doesn't because his his his
arrows isn't directed towards food he
can enjoy a feast without becoming a
slave of his belly right because his
arrows isn't you know and so so because
of that and right in some way that's
like kind of The Secret of asceticism in
some ways right is that if you if you
don't live for the pleasures you end up
actually being able to to to find
pleasure in the world more than you did
before it is Chesterton that that kept
saying that it's like you know when I
became a Christian and I stopped just
thinking about cigars and and food and
all of a sudden I enjoyed my cigars and
my food more than than before because
you know my highest my direction was
changed you know I wasn't just running
after after the things of this world so
it's there's an interesting idea that
that that the fact that that in some way
Socrates is beyond what aristophany says
is why he he can look up let's say yeah
look no this is this is all great I mean
let me so let me let me go back um the
the beginning points are really
fundamentally different in the case for
example of Aristophanes and over there I
put he see it and Homer and the rest and
Socrates so Aristophanes again we start
with chaos these chaotically bouncing
around guys and then you got to have
order and it's the gods right it's the
okay so here's the thing you're going to
sacrifice to the gods you're going to
have rituals you're gonna obey the God's
laws that you know and Zeus will strike
you down if you don't okay but Socrates
doesn't start with chaos Socrates starts
with an internal guidance system he
doesn't need external
um
um moderation or externally imposed like
you you know now you guys are going to
walk upright you're not going to roll
around and so forth because he's not
chaotic to begin with the internal
guidance system is bureaus and you're
absolutely right John you know the
ultimate object of Euros is beyond
intelligibility right I mean he calls it
the beautiful here let's say the good in
the Republic right you can't look at the
sun you can't you know good is beyond
being being
um
but
so let's go back to what John was saying
about sorry Jonathan about about the
horizontal and the vertical right so
when Socrates looks at another human
being what does he see he sees the
glimmer first he sees the he's I mean we
have that ladder of Heroes and that's
that's an articulated
uh Ascent right so you look and remember
how he says you fall in love with
another body then you fall in love with
the Soul by the way this is uh
phenomenologically correct right you
know you know you go back to when you're
a kid and you're like oh she's cute or
something and then you realize like well
you're actually interested in the soul
of this individual and so forth so so he
relates horizontally because he knows
that the horizontal leads up
let's take his relation to air to Al
somebody suppose that he had slept with
alcibiotes
by the way that's a very aggressive act
right also body is like I'm gonna sleep
with him
I think the way I look at that is if he
sleeps with Socrates it shows that
Socrates he's taken him down right but
you really care about is my body I'm the
you know he's the Marilyn Monroe of
Athens okay and Socrates doesn't sleep
but the Marilyn Monroe of Athens you
know uh and it's very insulting to ask
somebody but that is
a gift to El sobieties you see if if he
had slept with him I mean how cheap how
what a what a what a disappointing like
victory that would be you know there's I
mean it's out of respect that he doesn't
sleep with him
um why because there's there are higher
things and so with this account there's
this internal guidance system and it
leads you up and I I agree with you
Jonathan this is this is what makes this
is what accounts both for his Equanimity
and his ability to enjoy to be with
other human beings and it's the
secretive Community what is community it
is both the unity and diversity that we
you know you can't have a community
without individuals uh you can have
individuals without a community but you
can't have that Unity without each
person being
themselves and yet being together
um and of course the story of Babel is
like it's a big mistake right because
the human beings in Babel I've always
thought the bricks that they're they're
burning these bricks the the language
they make the bricks out of Adama which
means the soil the ground which is where
the word Adam comes from is made from
the so it's like we take these and we
baked the crap out of them and there's
nothing there and then they're just
bricks in the wall right it's just
fixing the wall that's right yeah well
you see the same in in Exodus you have
the same sense in which the Pharaoh is
wanting to reduce Israel to basically
bricks in his system it's like that he
doesn't he he gets rid he wants to get
rid of the male so that they're only
something to act upon something to kind
of to make into part of the system so
the Babel uh Egypt can see the structure
uh and interestingly like we often say
that in in Christianity who said that
Pentecost is the anti-babel right and
the reason why it's the anti-babel is
that it's both at the same time and so
it's all people hearing the one message
in their own tongue and so there's a
unity and multiplicity kind of almost
like a extreme unity in multiplicity
which is which is kind of proposed as a
paradox uh simultaneous simultaneously
yeah you know I mean so Babel's very
interesting because so that's in Genesis
11. Genesis 10 is another account of the
origin of languages which is a sort of
organic one I actually feel sorry for
the people of Babel and you know why
it's a strange story right the people
came out of the east or whatever here
they come and they say let's build us
this city in this Tower right so we're
you know so that we're by protected
we're not going to be dispersed
protected from the flood they just had a
massive flood in the story it's like
they want to make something high so they
don't get taken out by the waters
exactly and you know looking back I mean
obviously there's going to be historical
memory of all these things now their
mistake is I mean if you sort of think
about it like well who caused the flood
God you're going to make this hard hard
target right are you going to protect
against God that that's not going to
work but so I mean you know I could I
can understand these guys I mean they're
mistaken but they're you know they're
trying to sort stuff out
um well you just say you can understand
anybody who tries to create to save an
environment garment are too strong an
environment who tries to protect their
children so much that they just
them because they're trying to stop them
from being in any danger like you can
understand it right but you can also see
that if you create a perfect system that
tries to account for all accidents all
problems all difficulty you know I mean
then you're then you're actually going
to stifle create brittle a brittle uh
community that will that'll break
that'll crack because it doesn't have
its own resilience this is very opposite
today I mean this is exactly it you know
we've got these sort of ideals if we're
going to everyone's going to be safe and
so forth and you know I also think by
the way Elsa biodies
um he he wants to be safe he he doesn't
want to risk things you know there's a
kind of instinct there as well I mean to
expose yourself and say yes you know I'm
deficient and I'm ignorant and I need to
learn
so I want to see if I'm drawing a couple
of things together from both of you
um
seemed like there was an idea in
Socrates
um
that the vertical vertical Dimension the
anagogic dimension
in which he's caught up in kind of a
paradoxical relationship to the
non-intelligible source of
intelligibility
that
allows him right Equanimity in the face
of the extremes of the human spirit I
heard that argument sort of emerging
right so it's not that he it's not that
he is stepped out of his Humanity
because he can Feast but he can all
spread so I'm hearing it's safe you you
coming together saying like you you get
into this relationship right and it's
incompletable and everything right and
it and in that sense it's properly
paradoxical but if you live if you live
the verticality of the Paradox you can
get Equanimity within the horizontality
of the human the extremes of the human
Spirit I'm hearing that argument being
made is that is that Landing as as no I
think at least that that's what I yeah I
really think that it makes it's actually
what makes something real is its
connection to the vertical relationship
and so but it has to connect a vertical
in a way that allows the tension of the
horizontal to be livable right so people
don't lose their humidity Socrates is
equanimity is the preservation of his
Humanity even as it's Torn Between all
of these extremes that we've been
talking about that's what I'm also
hearing the argument drawing together
did I just impose that on you Jonathan
or is that fair no I I totally I totally
agree with that yeah I think that's
absolutely right and I would also point
out here that um the vertical Dimension
is not going to work if it's conceived
in the way Aristophanes conceives it
because what's on the top is Zeus and
Zeus is just force it's just he's just a
big rapist on the top of the mouth right
exactly exactly so you've got to have a
Socratic or religious conception of of
this vertical there has to be
Transcendence up here and only then are
you going to get this you know and today
I'm afraid again I mean there are many
Echoes of our situation it's like we
have Zeus right it's like okay here's
the order here's the structure right
whatever it's going to be it's coming
down it doesn't really have a logos it
doesn't in any kind of expanded sense
but it's control right and that's not
going to work
um the society will fall apart
and so you know again going back to
Socrates his attitude is really
remarkable it's
um it's a kind of engaged Detachment you
know like I I think of Socrates as like
a really good sport you know you have a
game and you play really really hard and
win or lose it's okay you know you gave
it your best and
um
I mean it's like in in the dialogue they
say well we shouldn't drink very much
right they're hungover from the day
before and like and Socrates he'll drink
or he won't drink it doesn't matter
right he's he's you know he's he's sort
of easy going reminds me John since
you're since you're you're working with
Kierkegaard now of the the night of
faith and fear and trembling this guy
who's just uh easy going and you know he
imagines his wife's gonna make him a
delicious dinner and he gets home and of
course it's the usual stuff it's all
fine he has oh
you see it in the Symposium Socrates
stops on the way to Agatha that's how I
said he thinks and then Elsa bites at
the end because it's by the way the
whole speech of also bodies is like the
beginning at the end he talks about how
Socrates stood there and for 24 hours he
was in contemplation and all the other
troops very much very much what is it I
can't remember in the Symposium they all
get drunk and Socrates offers a proof of
the unity of tragedy and comedy but
they're all too drunk to remember yeah
yeah right and I and I don't think
that's happened stamp either I think it
points towards what I'm talking about
here Socrates is the is the mataksu this
way that can get give us
um I think Equanimity is a good word
Equanimity between tragedy and the
tragedy and comedy uh of the uh of human
lives yeah and so also this this
vertical Dimension I I should mention
that you know one of the things Socrates
does in any dialogue right is let's take
a dialogue like the lockies it's great
there's a couple of men and they're
trying to figure out should their son
study with this
and you know it's very practical
question right like should they study
with this guy who's using a newfangled
kind of weapon and then the dialogue
turns into a discussion of courage so we
start down here and we go up right to a
sort of high Universal set of questions
Socrates is sort of this always this
weaving motion right we're not gonna
like take off into the you know go to
the moon and not come down we're going
to come back down right that is to say
talk about courage so we can be
courageous
um and tragedy and comedy this relates
to it because if you're if you're sort
of on the ground and you're looking up
right that's one perspective but if
you're high and you're looking down I
would suggest that's sort of the comic
perspective right from yeah and in fact
Kierkegaard has something about this
also in concluding in scientific
PostScript when you when you look up
from beneath with with the Divine sort
of in Prospect it's tragic but when you
look down and you turn around the way
that's behind you it's it's comic
um don't you think in some ways because
I just keep having Dante that's just
keeps flashing back at me you know
because it seems like Dante is working
all this out in the comedy you know the
the the problem of all these you know of
all these it's his whole thing is about
arrows basically right ABI Dante
everything that he writes is about
arrows everything is about how the
problem of desire and the proper
alignment of design the proper
directionality of desire and then in
some ways that's also what Dante does is
to reconcile tragedy and comedy in that
text because obviously the beginning of
that story is clearly tragic and then
once you move up you have this
transformation that that occurs
um well although I would just point out
though The Inferno does have comedy in
it remember those uh those demons who
are like in the mud and they're chasing
around and all this stuff I mean it's
interesting but I I take your general
points for sure yeah
um so yeah the question
oh sorry this is a very Socratic thing
to do I'm going to bring the question
back again I think this has been a good
argument that's made uh but again Plato
makes it very clear there's no necessity
to this I I think I think you're right
Jacob the up and down I mean I think uh
David David David DC Schindler in uh
impure reason makes an excellent
argument right that and you you even see
it in the myth of this you you go out
but you go back down right the up and
the down or like always have to be
maintained they both have to be
addressed the apps if the if the
absolute does not reach into the
relative it's not truly absolute and
things like those kinds of arguments uh
which of course Christianity has done
some amazing uh things with
um and um
but for me it's still I still like like
what is it
what is it that makes daunted a lot of
people their Eros is disproportionate
it's out of proportion it lacks latio I
mean that's why Virgil is there to
remind us that right Virgo represents
ratio in a really important way right
it's like but where like
where where comes forth
the the drive to bring proper proportion
to one's error all right okay I see what
you mean yeah yeah where does it come
from
I mean I think
it comes from suffering
that's what I I mean I think that it's
when we suffer that that we
it's when we suffer that we have the
sobriety to measure our arrows like it
seems to me that that can but we can
also because of our suffering turn into
resentment that's right right suffering
is an opportunity you could say but
you're asking why would one choose one
and one choose the other I I understand
your question that's a tough one I I I
don't I I mean I there's practices one
can do and things like that but you know
uh uh Socrates has this demonium and
other things and for those of us who
don't have that what is Plato calling us
to do I'm sorry I want I'm going to keep
pounding on this because this is for me
this I agree with the argument that's
been made and you you said I I
understood it properly the vertical
right the vertical relation with the
Paradox allows you to properly
proportion right the the horizontal
tensions and that gives you Equanimity
and and that's why the two are
completely the up and down is I get I
think that's a good argument but for me
I I and I think you know one of the one
of the criticisms
um no not criticism
one of the comments that David makes is
you know you see in Plato this too and
other sort of keeps trying to find the
starting point like where does this
start how does it start and I I'm sorry
he's infected me with this question I
think yes but what is it like and I and
I think about this I think about the the
person who wants to offer the logos in
the face of the sophist the complete
sophist like sort of derida on
amphetamines or something right it's
like like
what they're going to keep saying
they're just going to keep saying oh but
all is they're going to do the
hermeneutics of Suspicion because
Underneath It All what causes the
proportion is just a deeper desire that
you're not acknowledging and that's the
deeper desire for dominance or power
because that's the that's the deepest
and most and and they have no
justification for making that argument
I'm not I'm not I'm not agreeing with
that argument I'm just trying to ask the
question of what is it that turns us
well look
this is a super profound question uh let
me say that
um Plato I think leaves it open if we
look at the mythiver at the end of the
Republic remember the myth of verse yes
yes you know and
um people who have lived virtuous lives
then they go and they're judged and
they're sent off for a thousand years to
something like heaven right and people
who have lived bad lives they're go for
a thousand years of punishment and then
they come back and it's like this figure
eight it's like Infinity yes and people
make the next choice of the next life
based on their experience uh of this
punishment or delight and the tragic
thing is that ER who comes back and
reports says the horrible thing is that
for most people it was an exchange of
goods for ill so you know you live a
good life you're up there for a thousand
years you enjoy yourself and then and
then you yeah yeah you choose you choose
a tyranny or something like that and he
talks about one guy who came down and
didn't read the fine print on the life
he chose and he chose a tyranny but
those who've been suffering right they
come back and they choose carefully and
they choose a you know a decent life but
then of course they drink of the river
of forgetfulness before they're
incarnated so they forget all that stuff
but then there are these people called
philosophers and let's just call let's
just for the sake of argument Say by
philosopher what we mean now is someone
who has the correctly ordered Soul right
someone who has solved this problem that
you're pointing to John
um
the question that's never resolved is
how do those guys like those guys don't
choose on the basis of
of their most recent experience exactly
and and they don't drink as much of that
water or forgetfulness so that they'll
remember this right where did they come
from and I thought about this a lot and
and all I can say is that's what what
Plato does is he doesn't show how soccer
how philosophy is possible he shows that
it is actual right that is to say here's
Socrates I can't explain him now you can
look at someone like Dostoyevsky right
there's a sense in Reading Dostoyevsky
and you look at people who are either
saved or Damned
and there's a way in which
on some high metaphysical level the
human being makes a choice
like I don't know how to explain it but
you know there is a sense in which it is
up to us that I think we have to believe
that and like Jonathan said I like this
idea of suffering I mean I know look as
you get older
as I get older I get more moderate you
know my Eros was I was sort of a circle
person and now I'm kind of and because
you realize like the limits and you the
more you learn and the more you know the
more you understand that you don't know
and and you're more cautious and so
forth and
um but
um you know fortunately I haven't had
like any really horrible suffering I
don't know what that would do to me uh
but I would hope that it would it would
it would turn to it I would be able to
turn it to Advantage but I don't know
what the source of that would be if
that's the case yeah I just don't for
sure like mythologically in the Bible
that seems to be
what's happening right it's like death
is the cure for this problem uh and that
sounds like a horrible thing to say but
it seems to be what what that is is that
uh
dying is the capacity to to to change
and the suffering and and death is the
is the the capacity to notice the the
Gap right like when you suffer you see
the Gap and so
the the weird thing about the the weird
thing about the Christian answer seems
to be something like
ex choose to to die on purpose seems to
be that seems to be the answer to it
it's like if you accept dying
without it happening to you
then then that is what will reorganize
your arrows and you know Jacob what you
said about getting older I think it's
I'm I'm experiencing it obviously
because I'm like I'm almost 50 I'm I'm
getting older and everything and so hey
is that crazy Nifty was a long time ago
man yeah for me but what I mean but what
I mean is that I can I can see that you
know my like my body is is is
diminishing right I can see that and so
I also noticed that my desires could not
diminish right and so and then I see
around me because I'm like I said I'm
coming close to 50. I see those 52 53
year old guys who who crack and you know
like leave their wife and buy a sports
car and
you know marry some 20 year old or
whatever and it's like you know and in
some ways
I'm noticing that if I die like if I if
I accept the death of my body
uh and and I and I let's say it it
becomes an opportunity for me to
reorient arrows and so death is actually
an opportunity for me to to be saved
from my desires like my body giving out
is actually a is actually a wonderful
thing if I can take it in the proper way
where I can see it happening and notice
that it's like it's like oh those things
that I wanted like I you know I want to
be beautiful I want to be in shape I
want to be this it's like you know what
I kind of have to let that go because
it's gonna happen to me now or later I'm
gonna end a frail decomposing body just
like everybody else and so I could hold
on to that and be the tough guy and and
try to to look like I'm 25 until I'm 60
but I can't do that until I'm 80. like
there it's I'm gonna hit that limit I
might as well die
consciously and then and I can notice
that it's doing that to me like it's
reorienting my desires necessarily or
Plato does the same thing philosophy is
a preparation of death right and then
and there's a connection between like
philosophy as that which liberates you
from the tyranny of the body and and and
and death says that which liberate
people from the tyranny of the bodies so
the theme is there in Plato
um and then
I'm trying to get clear so is it I mean
I don't want to turn you into Heidegger
or something is it um though is it our
it's something like
like in Tolstoy Ivan Ilitch always knew
he was going to die the way you know
that two plus two equals four but now
Ivanovich knew he was going to die
there's like there's a there's a
non-propositional waking up to your
mortality uh that can
um sober you up and perhaps alphabetes
never wakes up I mean I think people who
want to conquer the world are somehow
thinking they will they they will not be
mortal by doing so
um so it is
like an infinite regress where like the
four-year-old yeah but what came before
that but uh so I could I'm trying to get
at so is there a proposal here from you
Jonathan that what can make the turn is
somebody properly awaken me to their
mortality but for that to genuinely be
the case it's not something they do it's
something that has to strike them it's
something they have to suffer you if you
did like if you just State your
mortality you're not actually
experiencing your mentality you
understand what I'm trying to yeah it
probably depends on people like some
people it will they they won't
necessarily need a massive Blow from
life for that to happen to them and then
some people you meet that have gotten
that massive blow and then they if they
take it properly they're transfigured
you can you know I've met several people
like that okay but then you can also
keep your mind like a recent Saint in
the Orthodox Church said you know keep
your mind in death all the time you have
to remember death like that's how you do
it all the time
and I think this is a good answer and
I'm starting to feel like my question is
being addressed
um what do you do then since you both
are leaders of the uh uh of the Old
Testament I don't know if that's a
majority of way of talking to about it
to you Jacob but um
um you know
um
so Pharaoh keeps hardening his heart and
all the plagues keep coming and then God
pardons Pharaoh's heart
which sounds like yeah so in the end
right this can also right the external
can also do the opposite to you right
your mortality can somehow be a vector
by which what is Ultimate can prevent
you from ever waking up that's what I
take hardening the heart to me like
Pharaoh it was now impossible for
pharaoh to wake up right
um what do you do with that then I mean
that's in there for a good I mean yeah
that's in there for a good reason I I
presume I mean I'm not a Jew I'm not a
Christian but you know it could have and
Pharaoh continued to harden his heart
and that but no right there's this and
it's like it stops in the face it's like
what's going on there so what what do
you again I'm not just I wanna I wanna
hear more what what both of you have to
say about that
you know I think it's really interesting
that you mentioned that example
um
I kind of want to draw a connection
between pharaoh and alphabetes because
you know I mean what is Pharaoh doing
he's doing something that's very human
in a way
um and that is he's doubling down right
I am not going to back off like you know
and why isn't he backing off uh well I
mean and I should say I mean I this the
issue of the hardening of the heart I
think the best explanation isn't that
you know God did something to Pharaoh
that wasn't that Pharaoh wasn't inclined
to do I think it's that it's something
mysterious there but you know God
allowed pharaoh to be supremely feralish
you know like he didn't he didn't he
didn't sort of help him to see another
way he just let him do the Pharaoh thing
to the ultimate extreme right and and
and we can easily imagine I mean we we
see leaders today you know uh who are
sort of doubling down on yes on sort of
bad bats and so forth
um
so why didn't Elsa biodies like like
Socrates was the blow
I think he sort of split else about he's
in half in a way right Socrates was the
blow that Elsa bodies needed but it
didn't work yes yes it didn't work and
you know I mean I think
you know
Jonathan was talking about getting older
and
um how we react to these things like the
decay of the body and so forth and some
people react to them with
um you know uh just despair let's say or
you know it's the most horrible thing
that could happen
and other people uh see opportunities
there it you know I mean and so why
would you be inclined to take it with
Equanimity right well because somehow in
your soul you feel that they're to each
thing there is a season you know that
there's a kind of order right and I mean
so like I have a granddaughter you know
so I'm a grandfather
um I could imagine someone who says oh
my gosh I can't believe I'm a grant I
must be getting really old that's not
the way to look at it the way to look at
it is now you got an opportunity to be
with this wonderful child to correct
your mistakes as a parent without
obligations as a parent and so forth
then you know you can have a different
kind of relationship it's these are
doors that are opening
um so what's the difference between
these things uh I think that part of the
problem with both pharaoh and Elsa
bodies is there's nothing above their
heads
you know Pride yeah yeah I mean you know
the Jews Like This is the Passover right
in Easter season you know they wear
these little Kipas these yamakas to say
there's something above me there's
something above me there's no one above
Pharaoh he's a living God
and there's no one above all sobieties
and so he's going to be trapped in this
horrible
um Dynamic where you know I mean if
Aristotle is right that people who seek
honor want to be honored by those that
they respect and admire
and then if you say here's Elsa biot he
said he essentially respects and admires
no one because he's the greatest you
know uh then he's not going to be
fulfilled with the honor of all these
little people yeah that's the hegelian
master slaves there yes exactly and yet
he's addicted to it yes it's only
Socrates that who he truly admires but
he can't be Socrates and that's what he
wants to be well that's how I understood
the Pharaoh thing
like if you bind yourself enough like in
addiction then you get caught up in
something that binds you
um and that's what I so it's interesting
because in terms of Storytelling you
know in the story in the story of Jesus
you see moments of this this problem
they appear oh first of all Christ I
mean Christ presents himself as the as
the Capstone and the stumble stone is a
good way to understand it right it's
like the foundation stone and the
stumble stone at the same time and then
when Christ is on the cross then you see
it play out where you have two thieves
that are looking at the dying innocent
man
and one you know one turns away one
turned swords in one mocks one derides
and the other you know has a movement
towards uh towards him and so you can
see how the same Act Right the the this
this this dying man is acting in
opposite ways it's almost like a judge
right it's like it's acting as a judge
on the on the on those two people around
him uh and that maybe that's it in some
way that it that it actually can do both
it does both at the same time and and
like you said it's hard to know like why
how why we're disposed humility but then
why humility like why do we why do we go
in that direction uh and so so and I
think in the end what Jacob says is that
we we are faced in some ways we can only
ask that question of ourselves
like we because that's the only
experience we have uh and and maybe
that's probably the key is to just say I
don't know but I I definitely myself I'm
hoping I'm on the side of the one who
who uses this as an opportunity
yeah I think I think that's good
Jonathan I mean you know suppose John we
had a a convincing theoretical
explanation of your question it would
still be the case that we're going to
have to act in accordance with the
rights you know yeah and I I and I hope
it didn't come across that that's what I
was after of course but right and uh and
you know and we've got to sort of a Kirk
a guardian Point
um where
yeah there's this thing that you you're
participating in a decision being made
it's not that you don't it's not that
you make it and it's not that it's
imposed on you and you participate in it
so it makes me now make this proposal to
you that all of this feeds into a
fundamental thing within the platonic
framework which is the notion of
participation
um about the relationship uh the
relation of participation that
constitutes the vertical axis but also
constitutes how the horizontal things
are bound together
um and for me I guess I'm I'm sort of um
well I I I I I I I want to say something
like oh that I find that a resolution
although I don't find it like like you
said Jacob I don't find it an answer
like a theoretical oh look John here's
the formula X Plus y equals
determination right all right uh but I
do I do this idea that we are ultimately
things are ultimately grounded in this
this
this participation
you talked to Father Maxis about the
like the idea of synergy like that's
it's that's it's a beautiful way
like in some ways it's like you just you
know you you can't do it on your own you
but you open the door this little sliver
and a bit of light comes in and then it
kind of gives you the courage to open it
a bit more and so there's this this this
call and response uh mechanism you could
say yeah I agree I think it's dialogical
properly understood that you know and uh
there's what tilak and Plato come
together but uh but but even even that
Rick uh and I uh the remarkable somebody
said I should replace amazing with
remarkable groups then I get all ours
the remarkable Rick lapetti we're trying
to do about because the problem the
problem we're up against is the Paradox
of self Transcendence uh Galen uh
sproston made a very good point about
this if if Transcendence means something
other than what I am then I can't
possibly make it right
um and if it just means the extension of
what I am right then it's not
Transcendence it's just it's just growth
and but somehow we put the two together
with self-transcendence
um it's it's a paradoxical thing uh did
that first of all makes sense as a
paradox because I mean I would tend to
say it's the source like because the
source of what you are isn't you
completely although it's at the it's at
the it's at the origin right it's like
the the origin of something isn't in the
system but it without it the system
can't exist and so all the system is
pointing to that is pointing towards it
but it transcends it but not in a weird
arbitrary way it's it's actually the
source of it well that's what I'm you're
doing you're doing you're an acting
participation
and so I think there's something about
because what I can say and then give me
a chance to respond to what I'm saying
right I could say to you oh but what is
a self how can you how can there be a
self if it's sources outside of itself a
self is something whose sources within
itself that's what it is to be yourself
right and and and and then the answer to
that is well then what right but you
have to understand a self is something
that is inherently participatory and
dialogical in nature and that's the
perfect guardian and also I think the
socratic answer right the the self is
something that is inherently is
inherently dialogical and therefore
inherently participatory through and
through
yeah I think that's absolutely right I
mean look
um
you know uh from the platonic
perspective the soul
uh relates to reality I mean it you know
it relates to the good it relates to the
ideas it's open and it it that's where
its measure is I mean it's interesting
because if you sort of think about the
story of you know the Tower of Babel
like the question is are the measures of
God going to be the human measures or
are the measures of man you know I mean
and so there's there's a kind of um so
the self can't be understood without
relation without pointing to what is not
the self the answer to the question of
how this question of self-transcendence
I think in the in the platonic context
we're going to have to go back to Eros
right so yes exactly exactly right so
that I mean Eros can provide this ladder
by this relationship El sobieties is
Aristo you know aristophanic in the
sense that he's really seeking him set
his other half in a way like it's all
about himself his Eros is directed
toward this vision of who else sobieties
could be and
um so yeah I mean looking out to the
other and then it you know and then of
course this weird kierkegaardian thing
as well right that love of self turns
into Love For Love of another but then
that love of the other is actually the
fullest self-fulfillment
uh well I I was gonna I was gonna say
that I mean you bring up perfect guard I
mean aren't we all aren't we ultimately
proposing the final transformation right
Plato does transforming Eros and then of
course platinus also puts it in motion
right and then and then Christianity
comes and sort of says but but in the
end the love that puts you into a
relationship with the other by which you
come to fulfillment is agape right
because that is that is right that is
the love that creates the other that
then nevertheless has come from you like
because the model is the the parent with
the child and of course the giving birth
is all through the the Symposium as well
so is is is is is that what we're coming
to here that when we
like
what
what turns us is that that which
that we we are turned when we
participate in the transformation that
is always available to us of Eros into
Agape is that now coming out because
that's that's the thing right because
like it right there's a sense in which
if if I if I'm just
drawn to the other
rather than participating in the self
foot of the other I'm still there's
still aggression there's still violence
at the heart of it it's only in Agape
where that where the resolution could
finally come to be seen because there I
am it looks like violence because I'm
creating the other but it's exactly the
opposite of violence I am giving myself
over to the full giving and
participating in the other becoming a
self Beyond me and other than me but
nevertheless in relationship with me you
know what I like about that is actually
that's a wonderful description of
how Kierkegaard regards Socrates right
in other words yes you know here's the
thing about Socrates when Socrates is
relating to you you are the center of
the universe he is relating to you
there's a very beautiful
um uh a book called The Last of them of
the wine uh and it has a description of
Socrates
um speaking to the main character and uh
he's he's a boy you know and Socrates
comes and sits down next to him in the
grammar school and the kid turns around
and looks at him he says no adult ever
looked at me like that like his eyes
were just on me it was about me and so I
mean this is interesting because as you
know I mean Kierkegaard loves to sort of
have these kind of asymptotically
approaching lines you know Christianity
and Socratic yeah
Jesus yeah yeah very much yeah yeah
is not you know the the consumerative
gays it's the Midwife in Gays it's the
games that is helping you to give birth
like it's affording you to give birth to
yourself exactly exactly and you know I
mean this is one of the pleasures of
teaching I mean this is this is why
so many of us like stick with it you
know I mean because there's nothing more
fulfilling than seeing a young adult
grow and and and you know flourish and
mature and and bring forth wonderful
things uh that's the Fulfillment of the
teacher and I think Socrates was a
teacher so could the difference be
the degree to which
again I'm not looking for a formula the
degree to which people have been I'll
use platonic language here to read to
which people have been impregnated by
Agape is that the thing that can wake
them up because we agree to which Agape
is alive in them is the degree to which
they can waken up is that is that a
possibility that that rings with the two
of you in any way so in some ways you
would suggest that
that that it it's not just a self-willed
thing right that that you could
encounter someone you know that would
that would provoke like by that by the
by their communion by the way they look
at you by the way they they they treat
you that they could provoke in you that
response yes yes yes yeah I think it's
definitely one of the one of the
possibilities that definitely
I like it yeah it's very good
I think this is a good place to start
stop our first conversation though I
feel like this is not going to be our
last this was wonderful I really and I
have a lot to I definitely have a lot to
think about and certain links you know
because I kind of dismissed
aristophanese you know as the butt of
the joke and the in the Symposium and I
think though he's still he still is to
some extent for sure but but uh but
seeing it frame more as a as a
structural move between the different uh
the different speeches helps me to to
see how there's definitely something to
take from from his um from his myth so
Jacob thanks for this wonderful
conversation oh thank you guys it's it's
it's it's really wonderful to be able to
talk to both of you whom I admire so
much so yeah this has been great I
really I really appreciated this a lot
um yeah I I I I I like the fact that we
you know we
I hope this is not I hope this is not so
promotional I mean I'm in the midst of
after I mean I'm done but after Socrates
is still rolling out and we're doing
exactly this with the the piece on
Socrates and Purdue guard again
influenced by Jacob's wonderful book and
so I I found and I hope this isn't me
appropriating things unduly but I found
everything we were doing here just
wrestling and wrestling fruitfully the
way you know uh uh you know Israel
wrestled with god
um right wrestling very fruitfully uh
with the with this these questions that
are in so I'm very grateful for this I
you know I think this is an excellent uh
companion to uh that part of the after
Socrates Series so thank you very much
for that I know uh it just it's a gift
in that way so I really appreciate it
all right and so I will be I will finish
this though I will shamelessly plug
something which is that that John and I
were going to be in Chino California in
uh May uh and so we'll put a link to
that in the description I don't know
even though if there are places left but
if there are it's it's you have to you
have to get them because it's going to
be a great conversation the search for a
spiritual the quest sorry the Quest for
a spiritual home is the theme of the
conference and you can see how that was
all through what we were talking about
here today so I don't know anything
about this conference but I'd like to
learn more so
listen if you guys send me your
addresses I'll make sure you get a copy
of my book on Plano and the talmud so
great all right thanks to thanks to all
of you and so uh so to everybody
watching we'll we'll talk to you very
soon bye-bye thanks a lot bye bye guys